with the visible light work for my basal cell and my lump.
So the visible light is a superficial light therapy. It's not
rife light therapy that's going through your tissues and deep through your body.
It's going to work on skin and work on superficial things. So would the visible light be good for
basal cell? Yeah, it would be. It would actually be good for melanoma. It would be good for
squamous cell. It'd be good for surface cancers. It'd be good for surface wolves.
But it'd be good for my lump. Well, it's very near the surface because it's only going to go a few
millimeters deep. So probably not. I don't know. It'd be really hippy. But certainly for any basal cell
cancer, any surface cancer, any surface wolves. There's argument with different light
therapy, like red light therapy. Red light therapy is so good for you. Well,
they're taking a lot of the research that they're using to justify the benefits of red light therapy
from things that are going much deeper. So is red light therapy good for you? Well, yes, it is.
But don't think it's going to have necessarily
benefits to different organs. Now, there's arguments that, well, if you affect the surface,
you have this reflex change in the organ tissue. Well, I'll give you that. Plus, if you affect the
surface, you're affecting from a neurological standpoint, the brain that can affect other tissue.
I'll give you that too. So you can't deny that any type of there's closet effect when you do
positive things on the surface of your skin that it's affecting the rest of your body. Yes, there's
truth to that. So I am never against any of the red light therapy or blue light therapy or
red light therapy or anything. Visible light allows you to use
the multiple different lights. And it is the best, I think, light therapy machine on the market.
So I think it's a great tool. And yeah, that would be something you could
use for anything skin-related. And it does
reflectively and neurologically affect other organs this year.